this new leadership came in they came in
pretty hot they've dialed it back a
little bit I looked into some of the
numbers coming into this some of these
were compiled by their the Mis caucuses
enemies the classical liberal caucus
which but what they compiled here is
that revenues are down historically when
you injust for inflation and not only
big donors but monthly donors are down
and I looked into the actual reports
behind the numbers and it's
accurate except the lp did not adjust
for inflation which seems like something
you should do well what do you mean
raise prices like um the ra the
membership they're showing re like in
the lp reports the revenue looks kind of
like slightly up because inflation um
but if you adjust for inflation revenue
is at historic lows yeah but so what's
the your takeaway from that my takeaway
is that revenues are down monthly I
that's like you know that's like if you
have a job where you're making a 100
Grand a year and then you just keep your
job and someone's looking at that and go
like uh dude your your income is way
down from there I mean yes that's true
but that's I mean if you're blaming the
Federal Reserve then I'm with you but if
you're blaming the mis's C I'm saying
the Federal Reserve and the B okay we're
saying technically I mean usually when
organizations measure their historic
revenues they would adjust for inflation
that's not true if like Coca-Cola puts
out like earning stat they're not going
to adjust for inflation Coca-Cola isn't
going like they' be like no we took in
three Bill we had 3 billion this year
3.2 billion this year we'll leave it for
the audience to judge whether that is a
good or bad number but uh what do you
think is going on here internally well I
mean just to to be clear like I'm not
you know I have no position in the
libertarian party and like if you talk
to like Angela or someone like that I'm
sure she could give you a much better
answer than this I'm not like on the lnc
I just I'm I just do standup comedy and
podcast about this stuff but from what I
I understand about it there was they did
have this major problem with like this
software thing um I I don't exactly know
the details of it this is something that
started before the Mis kogus took over
and all through them where so a big
basic disaster of transferring data so I
think that hurt him a little bit but
regardless of any of that um it's like
this I think that the the state of the
libertarian party was no matter what
happened at Reno going to it was going
to be a rebuilding you know like couple
of years in this sense that there's a
lot of people who were very turned off
by uh the mises caucus in the
libertarian party and there were a lot
more people who were you know what I
mean willing to go to to fight for them
and that's why we won um in terms of the
the stuff with donors uh walking away
again like I said it's just to me if the
if the calculation is going to be that
well like like let me say it like this
right there are kind of these storms
that that come in where things are very
sensitive to talk about like right now
it's the Israel Palestine storm that
we're living in where it's like kind of
takes a little bit of courage to talk
about these things because you know
you're going to get this backlash the
storms end and then it's like no one
cares like I lab leak Theory any of us
worried worried about talking about that
now you worried about your YouTube
channel getting no it's fine you can
totally talk about it that was we were
in a storm a couple years ago where you
couldn't talk about that Ukraine is like
that right and for me Libertarians are
when we have value at the most is when
in those storms we're willing to stand
up and say the courageous thing this is
why Harry Brown writing uh uh when will
we learn on September 12th is like the
most amazing thing ever because the day
after 911 he had the courage to say that
the the only way this libertarian party
thing is ever going to work and grow is
if in those storms we have the courage
to say things now I'd agree with you
that could come without some of this
other stuff that's not help I want to
stop there though but that's not what
the mees caucus is doing I would say I
would argue they are how I mean that I'm
talking about every single one of these
uh conflicts so like the the Ukraine
storm when that came they were the first
ones standing up opposing that policy
right now in Israel doing the exact same
thing so like that's the type of thing
that I do think the mises caucus has
that they bring to the table is there a
use in that if nobody takes them
seriously anymore right like like I
don't think that's true that nobody
takes them seriously anymore still take
them seriously yeah don't I went from
being like yeah maybe I'll vote for the
lp presidential candidate to now it's
like I would sooner vote for anybody
else available on my ticket than these
people why so what what is their crime
that's worse than Joe Biden and Donald
Trump I mean I'm just I'm stunned by the
shift toward I don't I don't believe if
you actually I think put any of these
people in power I'm not sure they would
know the first thing about what to do
with it or how to actually craft any
sort of policy I mean I mean you have
text exchanges from Angela mcardell and
Michael Heist talking about how uh
personally bankrupt they are and how
much money they've lost in the process
of doing this I'm sorry but if you can't
run an extremely small just speaking
candidly here political party and you're
not able to you know keep your
supporters in any way what why would
anybody trust your competence overall
like I'm just very who are I mean who
are who's even running for president
this year right
but if the idea is you know you are a
political party and you are putting
candidates up for you know election for
political office surely they should be
people room da Dave was going to run for
president and you didn't run for
president and now they're kind of
flailing I is that kind of a many I
think you're I think you're kind of over
playing this kind of like no one takes
them seriously and it's like they have
text messages there were those text
messages
I want to comment on private text
messages that people like put out there
I also just think that's lame and wrong
also
not I bet I could find if I found
private text messages right like let's
say I just had access to all of your
texts with your wife and your text with
your husband I bet I could cherry pick
them and and put them out there and be
like look their marriage is failing look
at this one exchange that I we never
talk about how we're out of money yeah
okay well fair enough um but uh but I'm
just saying like you so I don't know
like you're telling me you got one
exchange these aren't messages between
spouses right and I also I but they
messages between co-workers still
they're messaging between I I mean I
don't know even technically what you
would call them but the fact that in a
moment they're like complaining about
something I'm not going to like draw too
much of a conclusion from that I do
think like yeah like there's been there
membership and and and money is down the
libertarian party historically has had
lots of different periods before where
membership and and revenue have been
down in fact they've had points where
Revenue was very down but membership was
very high they've had points where the
vote totals were the highest but the the
membership was very low there's been the
truth is that the libertarian part but
also for the entire history they've
largely not been successful that's the
truth we took this thing over a couple
years ago and it's a huge restructuring
uh um you know that's been going on now
in terms of like me not running yeah
look I mean there there's definitely
something to that like I was considering
that that was kind of like a rallying
point for a lot of our guys and I
decided not to do it um and so there's
been some disappointment about that but
I do think that like I'm I'm hopeful
that over the next year and over the
next couple of years this is going to
like be I almost think of the misis
caucus as like it was like this
cleansing thing where we had to like
return to like radical principles that
are what the party was started on to
begin with and then kind of like now out
of that has to grow like candidates
because that's really what rallies
people that are radical principled
candidat I want to take this seriously
because I agree with you right like
there was a reason why I didn't choose
to like tweet and take a little gleeful
Victory lap about the you know text
message and email Revelations about all
the trouble that LP was in right like I
agree with you that it's important not
to draw overly broad conclusions about
that but say you wanted to take your
argument seriously and you wanted to
look for these small green shoots that
are poking up through the dirt as to the
ways in which the mis's caucus takeover
has been successful where would you tell
us to look well like what what should we
look to as evidence of you know actually
it's pretty good trending it's uh there
there have been like what the
libertarian party always kind of has
only is that there have been local
elections that they've won and that
stuff does matter I mean there are POS
you know there are people where we've
gotten like on School boards and on City
councils and Mayors I think a couple
sheriffs you know what I mean throughout
the country again I'm not like Heist is
a better guy to talk to about all of
this stuff to like rattle off all the
names they have launched this uh the
mises caucus has launched this project
decentralized Revolution thing which I
think is a really great um like template
for how the libertarian party should run
and it's very different than the way
it's been used before where kind of like
the strategy for the libertarian party
would be like um you know you show up to
like your state affiliate and they're
like what can I do and they're like I
don't run for something and whereas this
is now targeting like winnable elections
with nullification Powers so that's kind
of like the idea is building this thing
where the national is kind of like
messaging and then trying to funnel that
into like the local winnable elections
with nullification po strategy of like
the sunrise movement I believe which is
like the organization that initially put
a bunch of money behind Al Alexandri
Casio Cortez okay right like like
there's you know a specific there's a
big infrastructure they're going even
more local than that which is like I
mean he was saying sheriffs are a big
one because they've got a lot of power
and um or like a city council member or
something like that things that are
people uh positions where you can
nullify Federal uh um laws or federal
mandates that's kind of relatively low
voter turnout so you actually have a
chance of winning right so that's kind
of the the plan and then the the thing
is that you know again like I said the
other thing to me is just that it is
like look there I'll I'll take
responsibility in some way that a lot of
my guys on Twitter are like can you know
can fly off the handle and say some some
wild [__] but the one thing I will say
about my guys is they don't compromise
on the libertarian stuff and they're not
going to be afraid to like you know say
the thing that will get you a lot of
backlash when it really matters now I
wish I'm like I said before I'm not for
a lot of the edge lording stuff I don't
like that that's not how I run my
Twitter I mean I'll insult people
sometimes if they insult me first or
stuff but I'm not like the
non-aggression principle apply to insult
kind of right my version of that like if
provoke I suppose I can be a little bit
vicious on there sometimes so I'm not
like saying I'm perfect or anything you
been vicious to anybody in this room
about say RFK junor no just k i I think
I think I think I was that you know
honestly I don't think you were either
um it was Michael malice who was vicious
uh oh yeah well Michael mice is a a
furious woman you got to be careful
about him on Twitter no I mean it's all
in good fun I I'm also the type of
person where I can just take it like I
don't care Twitter also kind of does
that to all of us you know like it just
it is this thing yeah it's just and it's
hard not to like get sucked into that
but I don't think I don't think like
what I don't think that I don't think
I've gained like a following in the
libertarian side of things because of
any of that I think like people like
like me because I'm good at explaining
this stuff and like to me that's always
that's the way people are converted to
you know like people will bring up like
that one time Ron Paul was on uh uh
Morton Downey Jr and he kind of snapped
at those people but that's never
anyone's origin story no one ever goes
I'm a Libertarian because I saw Ron Paul
on Morton dowy JR they go I saw him
explain history to Rudy Giuliani Dave I
think you're un possibly unintentionally
making my precise argument I am so in
favor of being bold and aggressive and
courageous and truth-telling and saying
that unpopular thing at an important
time I mean I felt very riled up in the
co days um and it sometimes felt like I
was maybe not at recent but like you
know one of the only people in my sort
of Social Circles very comfortable
sticking my neck out and being like no
[__] no you shouldn't be forcing me to
show my vaccination status at the door
to enter a New York City restaurant no
how dare you and to the extent that you
are going to force that everybody should
Forge them I'm sorry but like the
liswell forging services are open I'll
do it for the low low price of Z hey
thanks for watching that clip from our
new show just asking questions you can
watch another clip here or the full
episode here
new episodes drop every week so
subscribe to reent TV's YouTube channel
to get notified when that happens or to
the just asking questions podcast on
Apple Spotify or any other podcatcher
see you next week